we were at the
pump and i heard the shots and i turned
around and i saw the clerk
okay shooting the guys 9-1-1 calls from
this terrible gas station parking lot
detail the chaos on february 6.
and then the guy saw some kicks
police say max maitana seen here with a
bullet wound went into the store to buy
some chips for his fiancee and their
three children it was days before the
mask mandate was lifted ins maitana was
not wearing one he had told the clerk
that you know he's it's in my pocket
i'll put it on
the clerk grew more and more
confrontational sean o'callaghan is
smitano's attorney the clerk at that
point did not want to serve him
he still wanted to take the snacks to
his kids
so he just walked out it escalated into
a fight and then that clerk shooting
smitana in the back his attorney says
his family in the car with him he was
stealing from the store and then
he was stealing from the store
and i took his uh i was going outside to
get to his license plate and he
literally attacked me
the clerk also called 9-1-1 minutes
later he died by suicide
this should have never happened this was
avoidable smitana is now suing terribles
for damages claiming they're responsible
for the employee's behavior
he's angry he's upset that
this incident could have resulted in
his children not having a father anymore
and this family has since left nevada i
did email lawyers for terribles today
and we have not heard back we're live
near centennial center in tropical
parkway i'm david charns 8 news now